this is too is it really a list talks
about
do you guys want to come through
it's a list of things that would
actually
constitute some degree of success
the truth is that there's a public
narrative
is it a success is it a failure but a
lot of work goes on beneath the surface
[Music]
what both developed and developing
nations want is to be able to stand up
and say the world has risen to meet the
moment we have kept
1.5 degrees of warming above
pre-industrial period
alive i would want to see results of
promises of we are going to stay below
1.5 degrees people need to lead glasgow
when i say people i mean world leaders
but also the businesses that work within
their economies thinking this is the
direction of travel this is where we are
definitely going
[Music]
getting a pledge from all major
countries about how they're actually
going to reach
that target that they signed up to in
paris nbc's nationally determined
contributions every nation who signed
the paris accord promised to deliver
enhanced ndc's nationally determined
contributions essentially more ambition
trying to reduce carbon emissions
further and faster we need them from
everyone
we don't have them yet and we need them
particularly from the biggest polluters
and they need to be
plausible
we need
radical accountability to ndc
commitments
all countries must step up
yeah we need more clarity on what's
going to happen with the global carbon
price
putting a price on
globally so that countries who aren't
doing so well at cutting could maybe pay
others to cut for them you can imagine a
scenario where china's not prepared to
budge on shutting a few coal-fired power
stations
but as a result they can say all right
we will give brazil money not to cut
down our load of rainforest that
accounts for the same agriculture that's
obviously very complicated and
it's near impossible but they're going
to try and come to an agreement
even if it's just headline stuff
no more empty promises no more empty
summits no more empty conferences it's
time to show us the money we've had a
lot about this 100 billion us dollar
pledge from rich nations to poor nations
to help them deal with climate change
and to help
reduce carbon emissions more effectively
and i suspect that it's a pretty much
given that there will be a global
commitment from say 2022 that countries
will commit 100 billion a year in u.s
dollars to developing nations to help
with that energy adaptation i think i
think that's quite likely the question
is not will we get it it's what we get
for the money how is that money actually
going to be properly allocated how are
we going to know that's going to go to
the right causes are we going to put it
into different kind of wind turbines are
we going to put it into nuclear fusion
or something else that may not work i
mean
there is a lot of money
there's a lot of good will and there's a
lot of ambition here there'll be a lot
of wrangling
about how that money is used where it
goes transparency all that kind of stuff
which bank account it goes to who
divvies it up there will be wrangling
about that but the headline figure
should be there as part of the cop
package of agreements
so that's quite a long shopping list and
more issues
may emerge
as the countries get down to
negotiating in the room in anger and all
of their needs and desires and
individual domestic political pressures
become apparent
you